Dave from a political activist
standpoint with what you know the
strategy of Colin Kaepernick did it work
with what he was setting out to do
absolutely and I love the way you asked
that question because I've been thinking
a lot dan about the action and then the
deed and there's so much focus on the
action the anthem question not standing
for it we're not really looking at the
deed which is the idea of trying to
start a broader discussion about
dissatisfaction with how issues of
police brutality and police violence are
handled in this country and if we look
back at the last year we've seen other
athletes almost overwhelmingly African
American athletes trying to push this
discussion more into the mainstream and
using their form of reports so LeBron
James Carmelo D Wade and Chris Paul in
it in this very scripted fashion at the
ESPYs and they largely got praised for
it for a couple of days and then we
forgot about it Colin Kaepernick took a
bold action he also took aside he didn't
just say we need to bring peace to the
community he said there's a problem
systemically and I'm going to stand up
against it and by taking a side he
certainly invited a lot more he invited
a lot more criticism he may even be
jeopardizing his career but if the goal
was to have this discussion in a more
full way then you have to say mission
accomplished what's the one overriding
question you have for Kaepernick Mike
well what are you willing to sacrifice
how far are you willing to go with this
and it seems like he's answered that but
I think it's about to get a lot hotter
than it is right now I think they're
they're open questions I'm sure you've
read them about whether he's going to
stay on the 49ers that could or could
not be for football reasons but then the
bigger question is will another team
take a flyer on what is an obviously
talented player at a position that's
bereft of talent and that will really
answer the question about NFL owners
about what matters more to them public
relations they're overwhelmingly
right-wing politics if you go by
political donations or winning games
because if the focus really is winning
games then you want Colin Kaepernick
and at least half the teams in this
league how would you feel if the NFL had
a rule that made you stand during the
anthem I think it would be the sort of
thing that we would have to point at
with our mouths wide open because this
idea of coercive patriotism to celebrate
freedom is just it is dissolved on the
face of it and this is something that a
lot of people have been arguing for many
many years it's just a discussion like
this that brings it to a flash point
like why do we do this in sports we
don't do it before movies most jobs
don't do that before you start standing
for the national anthem yet we do it in
sports and not only do we do it in
sports and we do it in a way that is
largely coercive that it's like you know
you are told to stand and players who
don't stand I tend to be called out for
it in very harsh terms even if there
aren't rules to that effect and I got to
take what it looks so funny about this
to me that I keep thinking about what
happened after nine eleven in Yankee
Stadium at the last year's of George
Steinbrenner when they started to put up
chains in the bleachers to keep people
from leaving the stands and going to the
bathroom during the god Bless America
seventh-inning stretch and these are in
the last days of steinbrenner and one
person actually sued through the ACLU
because he was actually thrown out of
the stadium for trying to step over the
chains that existed and just this idea
of using chains I mean not figurative
change in this case what literal chains
to get people to celebrate freedom it's
not the worst thing in the world for us
to question it's also not the worst
thing in the world the question about
likewise quartz is used as a method for
celebrating the military and I've spoken
to pat tillman's mother about this it's
interesting how many people have used
filming as a way to bash Colin
Kaepernick but this idea of using the
camaraderie of sports the joy that so
many people have felt in sports to say
to mostly work in class poor kids you
can find that similar camaraderie and
that similar joy in the military and
you're not going to find it at
McDonald's and the whole history of
recruitment and connections between the
Armed Forces and the Pentagon and the
NFL is its own sordid history which of
course is now being investigated in the
US Senate
if you go back to Muhammad Ali's passing
and we've talked about this with the
ESPYs with LeBron and company you
mentioned them I just wonder what impact
Ali has had and will continue to have
with a lot of these younger athletes who
were not alive to understand what he did
how he did it when he did it why he did
it but now they're learning about it I
don't know if anybody's ass Kaepernick
who was the inspiration like what they
when did the light go off that said I'm
glad when this you know that that's what
I would like to know is I just get a
feeling those guys at the ESPYs were
inspired by what Ali did and I don't
know if Colin Kaepernick was as well I
would be a great question for him I
think it's interesting that the
celebration of ollie I think there's a
lot of ways it's opened a can of worms
where it's like I think a lot of
athletes are saying well where we
celebrating him for and why and what is
the courage on display I gotta take one
of the things that's being left out and
that was left out of the lot of the
olive celebrations is that he was in the
1960s in the words of promoter Bob Arum
one of the great promoters in boxing
history a quote unquote dead piece of
merchandise and if you go back and think
a look at some of Ali's most famous
fights in the 60 the fights we celebrate
today there were empty seats all over
the arena again Miami in lewiston
against Sonny Liston people were voting
with their feet largely you know white
fans we're voting with their feet and
saying we're not going to celebrate this
radical we're going to actually turn our
back to him and I think Colin Kaepernick
is going to start facing some of that
and it's something that that LeBron Paul
etc ESPYs protest that kind of protest
doesn't engender that kind of backlash
one of the things that Kaepernick said
was he said I don't care if i lose
endorsements and i think that's kind of
like crossing the real Rubicon because i
think the endorsement cudgel is one of
the things that's kept a lot of athletes
in the line over the last 30 years good
stuff Dave good to talk to you again
thanks for joining us thank you sir Dave
siren he's the sports editor for the
nation website is edge of sports com
always appreciate his thoughts his
angles on this the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience
you